[Musique]
bonjour Sylvie Berman merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité ce matin ancienne
ambassadrice en Chine au Royaume-Uni en
Russie auteur de ce livre on va le voir
Madame l'ambassadeur c'est aux éditions
Talandier merci d'être avec nous pendant
ces 20 minutes pour cette interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Oriane bonjour Sylvie Berman et
on va bien sûr très longuement revenir
sur le déplacement d'Emmanuel Macron
hier Emmanuel Macron qui s'est rendu en
Israël en 6is Jordanie qui est arrivé
hier soir en Jordanie qui rencontre
aujourd'hui le roi de Jordanie ça veut
dire que la France détient l'une des
clés de la résolution de cette crise la
France est membre permanent du Conseil
de sécurité donc à ce titre là a des des
responsabilités c'est un pays qui compte
dans le monde bon moins sur ce sujet que
les États-Unis hein il faut être lucide
quand même cela dit bon le président
Biden n'a pas eu de chance parce que il
voulait se rendre également à Haman
faire un sommet avec des pays arabes et
il y a eu les mensonges du Hamas
sur la les frappes contre l'hôpital donc
là Emmanuel Macron peut heureusement le
le faire il est allé bon aussi à à
ramala ce qui était important pour
passer aussi un message sur l'avenir est
un État palestinien et là évidemment bon
en Jordanie et puis demain d'après ce
que je comprends peut-être ce soir je ne
sais pas au CA également est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'Emmanuel Macron lui est
allé au bon moment ben il est allé au
bon moment mais il a eu enfin il a eu un
peu de chance parce que les les choses
sont un peu retombées mais bon le fait
que Joe Biden y a il a ce moment-là
était tout à fait
pertinent alors Emmanuel Macron a
rappelé hier justement qu'Israël devait
notamment accepter le droit légitime des
Palestiniens à disposer je le cite d'un
territoire et d'un État en paix et en
sécurité à côté d'Israël est-ce encore
possible après les derniers événements
alors c'est la position traditionnelle
de toute la communauté internationale
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est que depuis
des années finalement on a mis de côté
la question palestinienne il y a eu les
accords d'Abraham et les Américains ont
finalement espéré que une normalisation
diplom tique avec les grands pays arabes
de la région règlerait le problème or là
on voit que ce n'est pas le cas
évidemment le Hamas n'est pas un
interlocuteur possible puisque c'est un
groupe terroriste et que ces frappes ont
été absolument monstrueuses c'est des
pogrommes
véritablement en même temps s'il y a pas
d'avenir pour le peuple palestinien il y
aura jamais de paix non plus donc et
mais juste est-ce que c'est le moment
parce que Benjamin netaniaahou il est
dans un un désir de venger Israël après
l'attaque du 7 ct est-ce que on est dans
le temps du dialogue mais je pense que
en tout cas il faut donner une
perspective et ne pas effectivement
rester dans le temps présent bien sûr
qu'il va pas y avoir de négociation de
de paix aujourd'hui mais il faudra que
on on reprenne ça demain que la sans
benamine netania est-ce que lui il est à
même de les mener ces négociations
probablement non c'est c'est le problème
parce que vous n'avez pas de
représentant Palestiniens crédiible
aujourd'hui parce que le Hamas
évidemment comme je disais c'est un
groupe terroriste que de l'autre
côté l'Autorité palestinienne qui
d'ailleurs avait été chassé de de Gaza
et très affaibli et que il n'a pas
beaucoup de popularité même en en fait
que mmoud Abbas n'a pas beaucoup de
popularité même en sisjordanie mais
l'avenir c'est quand même une Autorité
palestinienne crédible et du côté
natanahou effectivement il est
totalement discrédité aujourd'hui il va
rester parce que bon ben c'est le temps
de l'union sacrée d'une certaine manière
pour ces c'est représent il est
l'élimination du Hamas en tout cas d'une
partie des structures du Hamas parce que
il est peu probable que ils arriveront à
éradiquer le le Hamas mais après
effectivement benyamineum n'est pas
le c'est très difficile parce que le
Hamas c'est effectivement des structures
militaires c'est un groupe terroriste et
en même temps bon ben les idées
diffusent dans la population hier
Emmanuel Macron a rencontré justement
marmodabas est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'appuyer sur lui euh pour pour négocier
quelque chose dans la région le
marmoudabas ça fait depuis 2006 qu'il a
pas eu d'élection et et comme je disais
il est assez discrédité auprès des
Palestiniens bon à Gaza bien sûr mais
même en si Jordanie euh bon la
colonisation se poursuit ça c'est la
responsabilité de de nataniaahou mais
c'est vrai que Marmoud Abbas a été assez
impuissant il a été actif pendant des
années il ne l' plus comment qu'on
pourrait aujourd'hui une autre une
nouvelle Autorité palestinienne puisquil
en est question mais c'est c'est
compliqué en même temps parce que bon il
y a des élections normalement pour cela
et c'est pas nous qui allons faire les
élections et il n'est pas sûr avec la
radicalisation actuellement du peuple
palestinien que le résultat soit
nécessairement celui qu'on souhaite mais
il y a dans les Palestiniens y compris
dans ceux qui sont en prison aujourd'hui
en Israël des personnalité qui pourrait
être des acteurs de la paix Emmanuel
Macron qui a dit hier vouloir que la
coalition internationale contre daesh
puisse aussi lutter contre le Hamas
c'est une bonne idée c'est surprenant
cette déclaration alors c'est assez
surprenant je sais que ça a été évoqué
avec d'autres pays avant avec les
États-Unis le Royaume-Uni l'Allemagne
l'Italie mais en même temps le cette
coalition est associé aussi à des
frappes militaires et bien évidemment ce
n'est pas un bon signal dans dans la
région je pense que le président Macron
va essayer d'expliquer de quoi il s'agit
aussi bien en Jordanie que au C parce
que ça peut poser des problèmes avec les
pays arabes oui bien sûr même si les
pays arabes sont membres de cette
coalition mais ça dépend comment on
l'entend si c'est des échanges de
renseignement si c'est des sanctions si
c'est le moyen de lutter contre le
financement du terrorisme ça a un sens
mais si ça prend une dimension militaire
ça ne sera pas accepté par r vouloir
quitter cette coalition même si si ça
prenait cet aspectl c'est un peu c'est
un peu le risque pour le moment c'est
plutôt une idée je veux dire c'est pas
il y a rien de concret rien de structuré
en tout cas je pense que le président
Macron va essayer de tester ses idées
auprès de ses in vous dites que ça déjà
été discuté avec Joe Biden et et et je
comprends que ça a été évoqué
effectivement avec ave il pas sorti hier
du chapeau comme ça
c'est des indications que on a oui
est-ce que ça pourrait nous sortir du du
statut quo ça ça est-ce que ça ça
pourrait aider euh une coalition ouais
ça dépend quelle forme ça prend je suis
pas sûr mais je suis pas sûre que ce
soit accepté par par les pays arabes les
pays arabes en réalité sont assez
indiffér enfin les dirigeants arabes
sont indifférent à la question
palestinienne mais les opinions arabes
ce qu'on appelle la la rue arabe ou
arabomusulmane
elle est tout à fait en soutien non
seulement de la cause palestinienne mais
malheureusement également du Hamas et
c'est igens doivent prendre cela en
considération alors Emmanuel Macron
avait été l'un des acteurs majeurs au
début du conflit entre la Russie et et
l'Ukraine hein c'est lui qui avait fait
les médiations aujourd'hui il est
beaucoup plus en retrait en tous les cas
durant les les premières semaine du
conflit comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquez est-ce que ce sont des
causes internationales des causes
intérieures mais je crois que le bon au
début il y avait l'espoir que il pouvait
empêcher la guerre et il a beaucoup fait
pour cela et c'est pour ça qu'il s'était
rendu à il avait des propositions
précises y compris sur les accords de
Minsk bon et et à un moment il était
évident que Vladimir Poutine n'allait
pas changer d'avis et que bah du
coup le président de la République a
évolué sur ce point aujourd'hui il est
en soutien total de vodimir Zelenski
et c'est difficile de d'exercer
aujourd'hui on sont beaucoup plus en
retrait sur le conflit israelllo
palestinien aujourd'hui on le S on l'a
senti en tous les cas les premières
semaines beaucoup plus en retrait sur le
conflit israélo-palestinien c'est plus
compliqué parce qu'il y a des enjeux
intérieurs son alors c'est évident qu'il
y a des je pense pas qu'il était en
retrait mais je pense que il attendait
vous vous souvenez également que il y a
quand même eu cet attentat d'aras sur la
scène intérieure et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles il pouvait pas
aller non plus rapidement en Israël il
est très conscient de non pas des
risques d'importation c'est un fait dans
les sociétés occidentales et il se
trouve que la France a à la fois la plus
grande communauté arabe et la plus
grande communauté juive et donc que
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible que
justement certains lui reprochent de pas
d'avoir des positions aussi tranchées
que par exemple on fait beaucoup
référence en ce moment à celle de
Jacques Chirac lors de son déplacement
en 1996 est-ce que c'est parce que les
choses ont changé pourquoi est-ce que la
position de la France aujourd'hui qu'on
accuse d'être un peu trop aligné sur les
États-Unis et celle-elà je suis pas sûre
que la France soit alignée sur les
États-Unis il s'est passé quand même
quelque chose de monstrueux le 7 octobre
encore une fois qui s'apparente à un
pogrom qui est un acte non pas de
résistance mais un acte de terrorisme il
est logique d'apporter un appui une
solidarité à Israël en même temps il a
rappelé quand même la nécessité de
reprendre les discussions en vue d'un
accord de paix et en particulier d'un
accord palestinien d'un État palestinien
et il l'a dit euh d'ailleurs à benjamine
natianou mais également et à la pire et
aux autres dirigeants qui l'a rencontré
qui font partie maintenant de cette vous
n'avez pas le sentiment que la crainte
d'emporter le conflit en France euh ne
justifie son positionnement à
l'international c'est en tout cas
quelque chose qu'il a nécessairement en
tête hein il ne peut pas l'ignorer on
l'a vu dans les rues de euh de Paris
mais en même temps dans la mesure où
c'est une position qui est quand même
équilibré c'est-à-dire encore une fois
d'un côté un soutien très clair à Israël
et en même temps la promotion de d'un
État palestinien et puis du respect du
droit humanitaire du droit international
humanitaire le le refus d'une punition
collective je crois que là sa position
est très claire vis-à-vis des
Palestiniens alors aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron est à Aman qu'est-ce qu'on peut
attendre de la Jordanie concrètement
dans dans ce conflit B la Jordanie c'est
évidemment un pays important c'est un
des premiers à
avoir accepté la normalisation avec
Israël de même que l'Égypte donc la
Jordanie compte et on a vu que à la
réunion du CER le roi Abdallah avait
tenu un discours extrêmement dur contre
les Occidentaux donc de toute façon le
dialogue est fondamental vous ne
règlerez pas les
euh les misunderstanding
les les incompréhension les malentendus
sans dialogue donc de toute façon il
faut parler est-ce que cette visite elle
VI elle est aussi liée à la crainte que
le conflit ne se généralise à toute la
région il a appelé hier le Hezbolah
liimané le régime iranien à à prendre ne
pas prendre de risque inconsidéré a-t-il
dit est-ce que ce risque existe oui il y
a un risque de d'embrasement bien
évidemment de toute façon le l'Iran
soutient à la fois le Hamas et le
hzbollah qu'ils ont formé et à qui ils
fournissent des armes c'est un pays qui
souhaite la destruction d'isra l'Iran
parce qu'il alerte les États-Unis Israël
sur le risque d'embrasement justement
est-ce que c'est c'est un peu le pompier
pieroman oui B c'est le enfin c'est
c'est une forme de chantage qui est
exercé par l'Iran effectivement je suis
pas sûr que dans les circonstances
actuelles eszbola est très envie de
d'une nouvelle guerre après celle de
2006 en même temps bon il y a des
escarmouches et le Hezbollah est
beaucoup plus armé beaucoup plus fort
que ne l'
à oui bien sûr il y a toujours un risque
maintenant l'Iran passe son temps à
appeler à la destruction d'Israël c'est
une chose de tenir des propos virulant
et une autre d' d'intervenir directement
mais en tout cas le message doit être
clair et c'est la raison pour laquelle
les Américains ont envoyé de de
porte-avion sur les risques économiques
oui euh certains s'inquiètent effet de
de l'impact économique de ce conflit
est-ce que ça peut prendre une une
ampleur importante d'après vous alors le
les conséquences économiques bon il y en
a plus pour les États-Unis d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'ils se sont
désintéressés du Moyen-Orient
puisque avec le gaz de schiste ils sont
totalement autonomes avant ça les
intéressait pour cette régionl pour
cette raisonl est-ce que ça aa des
conséquences en Europe c'est difficile
de le dire certain parl d'une crise
d'une crise qui pourra être d'ampleur
sur le plan économique oui on l'avait
dit déjà pour le la guerre avec
l'Ukraine et la fin du gaz russe là il y
a plus de diversification des
approvisionnements malgré tout et je ne
sais pas si ça va générer une crise
économique mais en tout état de cause ça
aura des des conséquences y compris en
Europe sur ce qui se passe à l'ONU euh
on a vu l'ONU divisé on a entendu hier à
nouveau les États-Unis afficher leur
soutien très clair à à à Israël euh
l'ONU qui appelle un cesser le feu
humanitaire immédiat ce qui a mis en
colère euh Israël est-ce qu'il peut
sortir quelque chose de l'ONU est-ce
qu'il sert à quelque chose dans ce
conflit alors l'ONU est très utile par
ses Agen qui qui interviennent euh bon
que ce soit le PAM l'otcha ou toutes ces
agences humanitaires le HCR en revanche
le Conseil de sécurité est aujourd'hui
totalement paralysé il était déjà sur le
mois MoyenOrient parce que jamais les
États-Unis n'accepaient de condamnation
de d'Israël et puis bah il est
aujourd'hui sur la Russie et l'Ukraine
et c'est vrai que Israël se méfie
beaucoup des des Nations Unies euh et
donc c'est très difficile aujourd'hui je
pense que après ces crises aussi bien en
Ukraine que
contre le Israël et le enfin c'est
Israël et le ramas pas pas la Palestine
dans son ensemble je pense qu'il faudra
reconstruire cette gouvernance
internationale et le sé est-ce que l'ONU
est-ce que le Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU aujourd'hui il sert encore à
quelque chose on a d'un côté des véau
soit russes so chinois de l'autre véau
des États-Unis des Occidentaux est-ce
que aujourdhui non aujourd'hui est
totalement paralysé mais ça veut pas
dire qu'on a pas besoin d'une
gouvernance internationale et je pense
que demain ça veut dire quoi qu'il faut
revoir les règles de fonctionnement de
l'ONU bah il faut surtout et
le Conseil de sécurité à d'autres pays à
d'autres pays il ne représente plus le
le monde actuel c'est le monde de 1945
lesquels des pays comme l'Inde comme le
Brésil ben les pays comme l'Inde comme
le Brésil il il y avait un groupe de
quatre états on appelait ça le G4 il y
avait aussi le le Japon l'Allemagne des
pays du d'Afrique également je pense
l'Afrique du Sud peut-être d'autres pays
et oui il faut regarder en fait un petit
peu aussi la composition des bricks
parce que c'est révélateur de ce le le
monde aujourd'hui les États-Unis qui on
le disait hier devant le Conseil de
sécurité de ont affirmé une nouvelle
fois leur soutien clair à Israël est-ce
qu'en faisant ça ils prennent le risque
de se mettre à dos le monde arabe
oui mais d'abord ils l'ont toujours fait
ils ont toujours été clairement le
principal soutien d'Israël mais c'est ça
aussi qui autorise les Américains à
avoir une position plus équilibrée et
demander à Israël comme l'a fait Joe
Biden de ne pas commettre les mêmes
erreurs que les Américains après le 11
septembre c'est-à-dire de lancer cette
guerre en Irak qui a déstabiliser tout
le Moyen-Orient et qui était une guerre
absolument sans
raison donc ça permet en tant qu'ami de
tenir un langage plus ouvert et en même
temps à partir du moment où ça reste la
plus grande puissance et la plus grande
puissance militaire bah les pays arabes
en tiennent compte aussi hein mais
est-ce que sil y a perdre d'influence
des États-Unis ça peut profiter à la
Russie et surtout à la Chine vous qui
connaissez bien ces pays oui ben le
monde effectivement a évolué le la
guerre en Ukraine a été un révélateur
puisque on a vu que les pays du Sud ne
soutenaient absolument pas euh le le
camp occidental donc les choses ont déjà
évoluer c'est vrai qu'on va vers un
monde multipolaire et qui est plus dans
l'intérêt de de la Chine et euh et de la
Russie oui très clairement alors vous
avez été ambassadrice en Russie vous
connaissez bien ce pays euh de votre
point de vue quel est le rôle
aujourd'hui de Vladimir Poutine dans ce
conflit euh c'est un sujet qui est
beaucoup questionné tout le monde
n'pporte pas les mêmes réponses oui mais
je pense que c'est plutôt pour lui un
effet d'obben hein parce que ça détourne
de la guerre en ukrainee que ces
massacres épouvantables bon bah laisse
un petit peu oublier les les crimes de
guerre de de la Russie et euh mais je
pense pas qu'ils attisent véritablement
le conflit autrefis fois enfin autrefois
il y a pas si longtemp certains l'ont
accusé hein d'être un peu d'avoir
soutenu le Hamas dans cette attaque et
vous P que c'est possible je pense pas
qu'il ait soutenu le Hamas dans cette
attaque en revanche bon à l'époque où
j'étais à Moscou il y a 34 ans Moscou
était enfin la Russie était le pays qui
avait des contacts avec le plus de
dirigeants du Moyen-Orient avec tous
sans exception il pouvait parler avec
tous il organisait d'ailleurs des
rencontres avec des Palestiniens ils
étaient très Poutine était très proche
de nataniaou H aussi parce que il y a
une communauté de plus d'un million de
de Juifs en Israël ENF 1 million de
Russes pardon en Israël euh aujourd'hui
il voit l'intérêt de soutenir
effectivement un représentant de ce ce
Sud global dans dans son esprit donc
effectivement il a évolué il est moins
équilibré sur le sujet je pense pas donc
il souti tient effectivement je sais pas
si tient directement le Hamas mais en
tout cas parce que hier il s ému de
c'est légitimement de ce qui se passe
dans la bande de Gaza mais certains il
ont vu un signe d'un voilà d'un
positionnement clair mais en tout cas
puisque aujourd'hui le monde est divisé
entre Nord et Sud effectivement il prend
le parti du Sud et donc des des
palestiniens contre les États-Unis
alliés d'Israël la Chine elle aussi hein
a soutenu enfin pardon c'est montré très
critique vis-à-vis de l'État hébreux
est-ce que ça peut être de nature à
déséquilibrer le conflit justement ce
alors positionnement de la Russie et de
la Chine j'ai tendance à penser que ce
sont des positions opportunistes parce
que quand
j'étais à la fois en Russie et en Chine
ils avaient des relations excellentes
avec Israël également et il n'avent pas
beaucoup de préoccupation pour ce qu'on
appelle la question palestinienne
qu'est-ce qui a changé qu'est-ce qui bah
parce que c'est revenu sur le devant de
la scène et qu'on voit les réactions des
pays du Sud et des pays arabes et que la
Chine comme la Russie tiennent à
maintenir leur leur relations avec C
payant pays AR avant tout avec les pays
arabes dernière question Christ oui on
s'est aussi beaucoup questionné ces
derniers jours sur la santé de Vladimir
Poutine qu'est-ce que vous en savez
vousz sement des contacts là-bas encore
ça fait plus de 10 ans ou 15 ans queon
se soucie de la santé de Vladimir
Poutine donc pour le moment je pense que
pas d'informationation particul plutôt
non mais à l'époque où j'y étais on me
disait voilà il est malade il bon il
était c'est un sujet récurrent il était
il faisait beaucoup de sports il était
plutôt en forme bon aujourd'hui moi j'ai
pas d'information particulière mais je
pense
que pour certains c'est plutôt un désir
et donc il faut bon regarder la réalité
plutôt que nos désirs s merci Sylvie
Berman merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pour nous parler de ce
déplacement d'manu Maron qui était donc
hier en Israël en 6 Jordanie qui est
aujourd'hui en Jordanie et peut-être
vous nous dites qu'il se rendra
également en Égypte on va remontrer
votre livre madame l'ambassadeur c'est
aux éditions taland merci Sylvie Berman
et c'est ce déplacement d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est la Une de La Dépêche
Christelle Israël Macron entre Guer et
paix c'est à la Une de votre journal on
en parle tout de suite dans le club des
territoires